now that i'm in america i'm finally
going to meet my son colbin which is
something i've been looking forward for
over like two years
the only thing i know that emily always
tells me is that he's so wild and i want
to see how wild it is like to be able to
judge by myself so
i'm really excited i can't wait to meet
him
um
so
i know you really want to go see cobin
but i just think like i haven't seen you
in like two years
that means we haven't had sex in two
years
so
i was
thinking well i got you something that i
think maybe
you'll like i don't know
so
will you get my purse really quick from
the back
i think it's right there
okay don't look though
so i got you a little something babe
what do you
think this is hard so i can't wait to
see this on you
[Music]
i am honestly excited about the lingerie
thing because it's been long it's our
thing i used to wear it like back in
china like i had one like sometimes i
could wear and then i could dance for
her and stuff like that i think we need
this for ourselves you know to like yeah
recreate our love life
our relationship in china was really
physical
and
i've changed she's changed
so i just hope that what we experienced
in china is just going to continue
so i was thinking maybe we could just
like have one night together you know
because i want you to see cope and
obviously i don't want to take away from
that but would you be okay if maybe we
had a date night and stay the night
somewhere
[Music]
i thought we're gonna meet him today
i know but
don't you want to have like one date
night with me babe
you know
i want to meet going so badly
i can't wait yeah
how's this possible i felt like she was
being selfish i want to see my son
please
give me a chance like
let me see my son as well i've never met
him before
[Music]